[Musique]
[Rires]
josé fait participer les jeunes c'est un
défi pour moi je dirais si j'ai un
groupe de 30 g peut-être 5 c'est celle
qui s'assoit sur le banc capote trop de
goudel phase critique tout vu qui a pas
son match des ducs
bonjour je m'appelle chain combos je
suis entraîneur de basketball et
professeur en éducation physique dans
les sports collectifs
on peut travailler plusieurs compétences
une tragédie qui est des autres et aussi
dans l'histoire individuelle mais on
travaille détermination la persévérance
au défenseur tchèque ou switch c'est à
vous de parler de vous
on recommande de faire 60 minutes
d'activité par jour mais selon des
statistiques et seulement un jeune sur
trois qui fait cette activité physique
la quotidienne
est-ce que c'est peu mais de nos jours
tous les jeunes un gadget électronique
puis ils sont juste restés sur leur
divan
parce que souvent la compétition fait
pas aux jeunes fac c'est ce qui veut pas
participer mais si comprend que on est
là pour votre plaisir vient pour
apprendre les résultats c'est pas grave
ça les encourage à participer
je vais te manger pas encore pu encore
dont on regarde le taux d'obésité ont
dit que sa pratique manqué de rappeler
en trente ans on dit que 9% des jeunes à
un problème d'obésité d'un facteur
causal l'obésité chez les jeunes ça peut
être un manque d'activité physique ça
peut être la nourriture qu'ils mangent
avec sa l'école on est capable de les
amener à adopter un mode de vie plus
sain
[Musique]
si tu regarde ce qui se fait dans les
écoles primaires ou encore les écoles
secondaires trouve toutes les écoles en
font assez pour stimuler l'activité
visée ça dépend des milieux j'ai vu des
milieux où on est beaucoup beaucoup
d'élèves dans une classe alors 60 élèves
en primaire dans un choriste qu'à son
physique
une fois par semaine mais c'est
difficile parce que les jonas est trop
petit trop d'élèves vient d'un jim
pratiqué aux enfants jouer les gains que
les endroits où les plateaux l'école n'a
pas accès à toutes les plateaux après
l'école sont souvent sont loués par la
ville de montréal est fondée qui
s'inscrit à l'extase d'élite sûr que ou
les ligues de batteries qui sont à
l'extérieur de l'école et lexine et puis
c'est pas tout le monde qu'il fait parce
que souvent d'un milieu défavorisé
ça prend de l'argent s'inscrit dans
l'ailé parce que moi j'étais chanceuse
je vous dise pas bon entraîneur m'a
appris beaucoup beaucoup de choses alors
c'est à mon tour de redonner